Democrats are embroiled in yet another
anti-semitism scandal after
congresswoman to leave talked about
quote the calming feeling she gets when
thinking about the Holocaust about how
Palestinians help create a safe haven
for Jews after the Holocaust a calming
effect okay this is sick beyond measure
take a look and there's you know there's
a kind of a calming feeling I always
tell folks when I think of the Holocaust
and the tragedy of Holocaust and the
fact that it was my ancestors
Palestinians who lost their land and
some lost their lives their livelihood
the human dignity their existence in
many ways have been wiped out and some
people's passport I mean just all of it
was in the name of trying to create a
safe haven for Jews post the Holocaust
here with reaction to discuss the
Democrats anti-semitism scandal that
just keeps growing
also tonight's breaking news on the
Attorney General bar assigning a federal
prosecutor to look into the origins of
the Russia probes Texas senator Ted Cruz
well first we have Omar's comments
senator now we have multiple - leaves
comments and then we've got Believe It
or Not which shocked me and the mom
brought in by Nancy Pelosi who in 2017
posted an image on social media
supporting the Muslim Brotherhood in
2014 actually posted quote God willing
on this blessed night as the third
intifada begins the beginning of the end
of Zionism is here may Allah help us
overcome this monster meaning Israel
protect the innocent of the world and
accept the murdered as martyrs okay
that's Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the
House that invited this radical what is
going on
well it's unfortunately a growing
problem that the Democratic Party as a
whole is galloping to the left and then
one of the components of that is the
extreme left has a long history of
anti-semitism of anti-israel hatred
we're seeing
with this freshman trio these three
freshmen House members who keep
expressing anti-semitic anti-israel
comments whether it is congressman -
leaves comments about the the Holocaust
which which are just that they're
horrifying or whether it was
congresswoman Omar's
tweet attacking Israel saying it's all
about the Benjamins I mean it's it's
it's repeating anti-semitic attacks and
and it would be one thing if it's just a
couple of fringe fringe radicals in
their party but what we've seen is at
least in the House of Representatives
the Democratic Party as a whole the
leadership as a whole is unwilling to
distance themselves from these radicals
they're unwilling to distance themselves
from from these extreme and really
harmful sentiments you know for Nancy
Pelosi to invite that person is
unbelievable let's go to our breaking
news the Attorney General assigning this
US Attorney from Connecticut mr. Durham
a federal former prosecutor he now will
look into the beginnings of all of this
the FBI's ties etc etc in this case also
we have the inspector general Horowitz
we have John Huber his report the
Attorney General's longer investigation
and deeper into the investigation into
both the rigged in big de lection of
Hillary and/or rigged investigation of
Hillary the FISA abuse and the abuse of
power that happened thereafter nevermind
the well intelligence community
surveilling unmasking American citizens
and leaking raw intelligence well look I
think it is a good development that the
Attorney General has assigned a US
Attorney to investigate the the origins
of the Obama administration surveilling
the trunk the the Trump campaign it is a
very dangerous thing when law
enforcement or the intelligence
community is used as a political weapon
when it's used to target your political
adversaries I'll tell you as I travel
Texas I hear from Texans all over the
state how come there's no accountability
how come the Obama administration was
able to weaponize the Department of
Justice and the intelligence world the
FBI I'm very glad Attorney General Barr
it is demanding some accountability we
need to investigate it we need to
Vesta gate how politicized it was and in
particular we need to see what were the
roles of the political appointees who
signed off on it was was it Loretta
Lynch was it John Brennan what was it
Joe Biden was it President Obama himself
that kind of accountability we need to
know when the public deserves answer
senator let me let me pick your legal
mind for just a second you you with the
national debate champion and I don't
think anyone can really we've we watched
you debate before are you can tell it
was one of the cool kids in college yob
viously I was not a part of the club but
on a serious note you convinced the
Espionage Act was violated by Hillary
are you convinced the intent of
destroying those emails was to cover up
an underlying crime and and eliminate
the evidence are you convinced the FISA
courts that a fraud was committed by
omission and using the fake phony
dossier the Russian dossier and are you
convinced it was an effort by deep state
operatives to undo a presidential
election after they tried to rig it
listen there there are serious and
concerning evidence underlying every one
of those that those issues you laid out
when it comes to Hillary Clinton and her
use of emails her violation of the the
laws concerning keeping classified
documents classified that there appears
to be even James Comey as politicized as
he was called it gross negligence but
there's also very deliberately an effort
to destroy evidence and an effort to
smash phones with hammers and using
bleach bit as you mentioned just a
minute ago to erase hard drives I mean
that's typically conduct that that
events is a guilty conscience trying to
hide criminal conduct and we need to
have accountability we need to have
accountability for each and every person
who violated the law law enforcement
should be nonpartisan it shouldn't be a
political weapon used against those who
happen to be on the other side I want to
be very clear the weaponizing of our
intelligence the abuse of power this was
not the 99.9% FBI this was not the 99%
our Intel community that protects us
every day senator good to see you thank
you for being with us